rien lâché on a beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder dans l'est un peu plus de 20
minutes presque 25 minutes qu'on va
passer ensemble à partir de maintenant
il ya évidemment l'avenir du parti et
l'eire qui est pas si simple à écrire
d'ici au congrès qui est prévue cet
automne les élections législatives qui
pourraient voir fondre le nombre de
députés républicains au sein de ce
groupe qui était jusqu'à présent la
première force d'opposition au sein de
l'assemblée il ya le rôle du sénat comme
contre pouvoir et notamment par la loi
de réforme des institutions voulue par
emmanuel macron la polémique relancée
par le maire de grenoble sur le burkini
on y viendra aussi mais évidemment la
première info pour commencer la
nomination d'elizabeth board à matignon
est ce que c'est un bon choix
écoutez en tous les cas je lui ai envoyé
un message ce matin pour nous souhaiter
chance et courage parce que nous allons
devoir
en avoir besoin tous face à une france
qui est inquiète et à une situation qui
est inquiétante situation inquiétante
les finances publiques vous le savez
elles sont particulièrement inquiétants
dans notre pays inquiétude aussi des
français qui dunke pour le pouvoir
d'achat qui nous vous avons vu lors de
l'élection tout ces fractures
territoriales notamment entre une france
plutôt rurale et une france
métropolitaine ça s'est traduit dans
l'expression au second tour même dans le
département j'étais hier l'heure je
regardais les résultats marine le pen
est arrivé en tête au second tour mais
est ce que c'est la bonne personne pour
répondre à toutes ces inquiétudes ces
choix du président de la république
en cinquième république
c'est un choix que je respecte c'est une
femme de gauche c'est une femme avec
lequel nous avons travaillé au cours du
quinquennat précédent je pense notamment
aux textures la transformation du statut
de la sncf nous avons même abouti à un
accord j'ai souvenir d'une négociation
dans mon bureau de rencontre avec la
ministre de l'époque qui ensuite mois de
rencontre pour dialoguer avec la cfdt et
l'unsa au moment de blocage la ministre
n'était pas présent mais c'était le
rapporteur et le président de la
commission hervé maurey et je dois dire
que nous avons pu travailler
tous les cas avec le cdh a élevé c'était
pas une contrepoids une densité plus tôt
j'allais dire et diallo courtois contre
dialogue courtois mais déterminée des
deux côtés elle a eu moins de succès
devant le sénat comme ministre de
l'écologie quand il s'est agi de fermer
fessenheim est d'ailleurs
il est arrivé au dit la décision dans
une question au gouvernement elle avait
dit que c'était un immense progrès de la
modernité et de l'écologie demain quand
on voit là la crise énergétique que nous
traversons là quelque part nous avons
aussi travaillé ensemble sur la loi sur
l'orientation des mobilités et nous
partagions ça n'était pas un texte sur
la réforme nation au chômage donc je
souhaite que nous puissions travailler
non c'est le tailleur de travailler au
sénat
c'est à dire à chaque fois que il nous
paraîtra pour la majorité sénatoriale
que c'est l'intérêt du pays nous
demanderons à nos instructions système a
lancé ce que vous laissez quelques
valeurs que nous étions contre-pouvoir
est est ce que vous êtes soulagés qui
emmanuel macron soit pas allé chercher
quelqu'un dans vos rangs écoutez c'est
son choix si savard s'arrêteront pas là
ma question d'euros mais ce son choix et
je pense que ce choix là il me donne
quelques orientations je souhaite que
quelqu'un ici de la gauche soit quand
même attentif à l'état de nos finances
publiques
je souhaite aussi que naturellement et
soient attentifs à ce que l'écologie ne
soit pas punitive souvenez-vous des
gilet jaune souvenez-vous antérieurement
des monnaies rouge je crois que hélas en
charge cette transition écologique c'est
doit être une transition concrètes
pragmatiques et partagé par des citoyens
et nos collectivités territoriales
équation elle est difficile à tenir mais
je reste sur cette question du choix
effectivement c'est le choix du présent
à public c'est on est vraiment dans
l'application de de la règle de la vème
république
mais si catherine vautrin que vous
connaissez bien la présidente de la
communauté urbaine du grand un sens yens
ministre nicolas sarkozy avait été
choisi pour occuper le poste à matignon
c'était plus embarrassant quand même
pour vous au bar à sion nous nous
connaissons bien et je vous envoie
tennis transforme dans le pôle borloo
c'est une fable et on en réalité
n'aurait dit emmanuel macron fait encore
pardon c'est un peu triviale sont pas
arrivés emmanuel macron moyen choisi une
femme
issue elle même du corps préfectoral du
corps des ingénieurs qui a l'expérience
d'avoir été ministre pendant cinq années
dot acte est maintenant au travail le
sujet c'est pas de débattre
éternellement sur fond d'accord qu est
le choix qui n'a pas été le choix mais
maintenant au travail nouvelle première
ministre d'ailleurs vous dites quoi vous
dites madame le premier ministre
est vraiment c'est comme elles le
souhaitent vers lui écrivant ce matin je
lui ai écrit madame la première voilà ce
que je vous pose la question parce que
ce matin sur rtl eric zemmour refusait
de dire la première mini 10 c'est pas
beau la langue française est plus belle
que ça y est ce que le milieu politique
français est aussi machiste que ledit
dit cresson qui était voilà il ya 30 ans
à matignon et qui depuis plusieurs jours
voilà témoigne eddi le milieu politique
français et plus machiste que la société
française je crois que ça n'a pas été
facile avant edith cresson une femme
pour lequel j'ai un immense respect
simone veil avait aussi connu sur des
débats de société des réactions qui
n'était pas nier je suis certain qu'au
sénat et car c'est même ce que simone
veil m'avait dit pourtant dans un monde
qui était beaucoup plus masculin à
l'époque je pense que la présence de
près de plus de 35% de sénateurs qui
sont des femmes fera qu'au contraire la
première ministre sera accueillie eh
bien on se confrontera sur les projets
sur les idées et on essaiera de
travailler ensemble pour le pays avec
nos différences alors justement ce matin
sur france inter christophe castaner dit
d'elisabeth bornes c'est la ministre des
réformes impossible devenu possible la
sncf l'allocation chômage est ce qu'elle
est elisabeth bornes la personne idéale
pour mener à bien la réforme des
retraites premier aspect de la question
et allez vous la soutenir dans cette
réforme réforme des retraites si le
projet qu'a annoncé le président de la
république est bien celui d'abord aux
réformes paramétriques way qui prenne en
compte la pénibilité elle a déjà été
écrit par le sénat aient voté depuis
trois ans dans le cadre du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
notre commission des affaires sociales
notre rapporteur rené paul savary notre
rapporteur général présente cette
réforme des retraites elle n'est pas
très différente et dans une rencontre
avec le président de la république est
dit au fond c'est la réforme que le
sénat a préparé donc donc aller
jusqu'à 65 ans vous dites oui
donnons-nous le temps ci du dialogue
social bien sûr l indispensable
c'est pas un ancien ministre du travail
aussi qui vous dira que le dialogue
social ce n'est pas important dialogue
social avec un sujet qui est la
pénibilité avec le sujet de la santé au
travail nous devrons traiter ces sujets
pendant cette réforme des retraites et
puis parallèlement à cela puisque nous
traiterons de l'âge
il faudra traiter de la prévention c'est
pour ça que je parlais de santé au
travail il faudra aussi et traiter du
sujet de la dépendance donc de
l'autonomie donc le sujet d'actualité
les établissements qui accueillent nos
grands aînés dépendants
le maintien à domicile j'étais cet
après-midi même avec un président de
conseil départemental qui me disait la
difficulté aujourd'hui notamment depuis
la pandémie a recruté des
accompagnements de vie des aides
soignantes des gens qui viennent au
domicile comme s'il y avait une crise de
vocations pourriez qu'on est là sur des
sujets majeurs qui vont être ouvert à la
concertation sociale et dans lequel le
sénat va se mettre en situation d'un
d'apporter le fruit de son expérience
dans quelques jours nous aurons un
rapport très important sur la situation
de nos aînés notamment en ehpad et par
bernard bonne sénateur de la loire et
par michel meunier
sénatrice de loire-atlantique voiliers a
eu l'air une socialiste c'est sur ces
sujets elle à propos d' emmanuel macron
le 15 mars dernier vous dit vous alerter
sur l'absence de campagne l'absent débat
je vous cite à la question de la
légitimité du gagnant se posera est ce
que ce débat a finalement lieu écoutez
en tous les cas je l'avais dit quand on
poursuit la lecture mon interview
le 10 et le 24 avril les français
s'expriment oms et le choix s'imposera
donc en aucun cas je remettais en cause
légitimité d'ailleurs on s'en est
expliqué le président de la république
et moi je pense qu'il est juste après ça
dit non non non c'était un peu au delà
rien de plus tu t'en es ce que vous avez
regretté un nom pour l'instant soit le
point c'est pas du tout parce que je
pense qu'une partie des sujets n'ont pas
été traités et d'ailleurs le vrai débat
il n'a eu lieu qu'entre les deux tours
et naturellement il est est réducteur et
simplificateur parce que quelqu'un comme
moi qui a appelé à voter emmanuel macron
second tour est clairement oui
clairement aux jeunes on ne l'a pas fait
dans votre dos mais je les fais
clairement je me suis exprimé dans la
presse
on voit bien que le débat était quelque
peu raccourci y compris avec des
allers-retours sur la question des
retraites pendant ces deux semaines là
mais nous verrons le projet qui va être
déposée nouveau président nouveau mandat
voilà ce qu'a affirmé emmanuel macron
lors de son investiture il promet
également une nouvelle méthode je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'on disait la
première ministre c'était hier lors de
la passation de pouvoir on écoute
elisabeth bornes dont nous partageons la
conviction que les politiques publiques
doivent se bâtir dans le dialogue le
dialogue avec les élus avec les
partenaires sociaux avec les
associations avec lesquelles nous avons
travaillé sans relâche tous ces derniers
mois et je suis convaincu que nous
pourrons le faire en associant encore
davantage les forces vives de nos
territoires est ce que c'est bien au
plus près des français qu'on trouvera
les bonnes réponses et c'est bien tout
le sens aussi de la nouvelle méthode
voulue par le président de la république
en creux gérard larcher est ce que ça
veut dire qu emmanuel macron n'avait pas
la bonne méthode lors de son propre
outil en tous les cas 12 ont pu éprouver
cette méthode cette méthode c'est de
verticalité de décision qui arrive d'en
haut d'une absence de dialogue avec les
élus j'ai entendu dans le discours
d'investiture du président de la
république
son souhait d'un dialogue
exécutif parlement est extrêmement
important dialogue avec le parlement
avec naturellement les partenaires
sociaux avec les forces vives il avait
simplement oublié les élus locaux mais
j'ai eu l'occasion de lui dire que je
pensais que ça n'était qu'une ambition
et je suis certain que ce n'est qu'une
émission comme ça il nous faut retrouver
cette proximité qui manque tant qui
s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé parce que quand vous avez un
vote de premier tour ou spread 60% des
votants
ne veulent pas j'allais dire pour autre
chose que des candidats issus de partis
protestataires vous vous dites ya
quelque part un vrai malaise
démocratique est encore à tous ceux qui
n'ont pas voté gérard larcher un malaise
démocratique et que nous devrons y
apporter des réponses alors justement
sur les institutions est ce que vous
diriez notre vème république est malade
aujourd'hui dont je pense la vème
république a de bons fondamentaux et ça
lui permet de traverser des crises le
président de la république souhaite sans
aucun doute de nous proposer de
réfléchir et il va le confier à une
commission transpartisane à des
évolutions institutionnelles ainsi vous
trouvez que c'est un bon principe on
fait de la commission a toujours existé
on s'épanouit la commission balladur et
commission je sais pas mais qu'est ce
que vous pensez prioritaire pour quand
même redonner à ces français qui soit se
désintéressent de la politique soit on
choisit les extrêmes recréer un lien
avec leur institution qu'est ce que
c'est quoi c'est leur donner la parole
plus souvent le référendum c'est quoi la
crise est d'abord la pratique
quotidienne et la proximité regardé ce
maire que nous avons entendu qu'ils
dialoguent avec les services de l'état
dé manière confiante ce maire il raconte
à ses citoyens
sans vous avez entendu le chiffre de
ceux qui n'ont pas de médecin c'est ça
c'est donc d'abord la pratique la
pratique de la proximité de
l'horizontalité suffira pas de faire des
réformes constitutionnelles
d'élargir le champ de l'article 11
notamment pour élargir le champ du
référendum ça ne m'en sortirais vincent
la proportionnelle vi et le président
l'a vu que c'est qu'il aura besoin du
sénat pour nous il peut alors il peut le
faire par une loi on est d'accord par
une idée simple mais est ce que vous
vous y est favorable écoutez moi je
n'étais pas veut aficionados de la
proportion pour ça je vous pose la
question je me suis exprimé n'y a pas si
longtemps
en disant que quand 60% je reviens mon
chiffre
de nos compatriotes france-soir premier
tour pour des partis ou des gens issus
de formations politiques qui sont très
peu représentés se pose la question
d'une part de proportionnelle tailleur
en 2019 au mans
débattions la révision constitutionnelle
ça n'était pas dans la révision
constitutionnelle et le sujet le
proportionnel faisait partie de nous
débat au sénat la majorité sénatoriale
avait dit qu'elle était ouverte à une
part de proportionnelle oui mais alors
attention ne pas perdre le lien oui oui
député de circonscription il a perdu
lire oui effectivement alors justement
c'est ce que c'est un peu ce que dit
philippe bas le sénateur l ère de la
manche ancien président de la commission
des lois il a dit à l'un des
journalistes de la rédaction de de
public sénat françois vignal pour lui la
proportionnelle éloigne le député du
citoyen elle affaiblit le lien
démocratique elle mais le député dans la
main des partis et je continue le site
et elle aboutit à une dispersion des
forces politiques il ajoute avec la
proportionnelle vous avez un pouvoir
parlementaire plus grand mais c'est un
pouvoir stérile car diviser et c'est le
risque de l'instabilité gouvernementale
bon yaya seuil à ce discours dans la
majorité l'air aux sélections que il et
je repose la question à quel point les
accompagnent emmanuel macron dans sa
légitime puisque nous avions travaillé à
l'époque avec philippe bas mais nous
nous en étions tenus à une proposition
sur une part limitée proportionnelle qui
ne fasse pas disparaître la
circonscription législative ce lien
proximité qui évoque philippe bas et que
je partage vous savez on va rentrer le
parlementaire dans sa permanence parce
qu'il a un territoire c'est la
circonscription pardonnez-moi de
rambouillet et ça a du sens si ça
devient une liste proportionnelle même
départemental ou national
une part de proportionnelle c'est un
sujet qui mérite débat bon ok est ce que
je vois est vrai qu'on parle maintenant
à gérard larcher de votre parti le parti
a l'air les républicains est ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour son avenir nous avons
subi un échec un échec grave à
l'élection présidentielle
notre poids politique ce départ quatre
et demi pour cent mais plus que cela il
n'empêche ils devront trouver avec les
français des relations de confiance nous
devons reparler aux français et
notamment certains français qui nous ont
en quelque sorte quitter nous ont pas
rejoint les français qui travaillent par
exemple
aborder un certain nombre de sujets sur
lequel nous devons être attentifs la
préoccupation des jeunes vis-à-vis des
questions environnementales et bien
après les élections législatives pour
lequel je suis engagé totalement engagée
aux côtés de nos candidats je n'en doute
pas mais pardon vous interrompre mais
depuis depuis trois semaines en semaines
et demie donc on a le sentiment de ne
pas entendre la voix des airs est ce que
parce que le trauma de la présidentielle
est tellement fort qu'il le quillan et
saisi votre politique voyez ce que je
veux dire me vais entendu chez vos
confrères et bien sûr et je suis sur le
terrain je suis sur le terrain je
parlais de leurs hier vendredi je serai
à nouveau sur le terrain et aujourd'hui
il appartient à chaque candidat aux
élections législatives
de rencontrer les citoyens nous avons un
projet qui est proposé aujourd'hui notre
responsabilité
c'est d'incarner une ligne claire et la
libre parce qu'elle est pendant un
besoin qui soit autour de nos valeurs
que vous connaissez la responsabilité
l'engagement
premier sujet maîtriser les dépenses
publiques n'a pas continué premiers
milliards de dettes 60% ça va être
difficile mais oui parce que l argent
magique ça rend accro et en ça rend
accro mais ça se termine en grèce il ya
quelques années l'argent magique
la décentralisation pour retrouver cette
proximité
répondre notamment en matière de pouvoir
d'achat à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
on ne pourra pas éternellement vivre
j'allais dire le chèque automatique mais
est-ce que l'échec de la campagne de
valérie pécresse s'est pas l'échec d'une
dune
défini finalement trop à droite c'est ce
qui est ressorti des débats des
primaires pour le congrès l'air quand
même et ce sentiment en tout cas perçue
par une partie de l'opinion que
finalement bas quitte à voter à droite
autant voter pour celles qui avaient le
plus de chances de se qualifier et donc
le vote utile pour marine le pen voyez
ce que je veux dire oui sortie 12
électeurs ont aussi voté pour emmanuel
macron pour éviter le second tour c'est
vrai entre monsieur mélenchon et madame
le mien d'accord en fait il est exact
mais ce n'est pas que notre candidate
c'est toute la démarche qui a été la
nôtre
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
revoir les choses ou du sol au plafond
mais
imaginez que l'opposition
à l'assemblée nationale soit représentée
réellement que par la france a soumise
le rassemblement national je me dis à
ceux qui nous entendent nous avons
besoin d'une opposition républicaine qui
à chaque fois des choses vont bien des
amendes les soutiens mais qu'ils sachent
dire non aussi qu'ils sachent les
représenter dans leurs doutes dans leurs
interrogations dans leur vie quotidienne
voilà pourquoi c'est me semble-t-il de
saluts républicains que nous ayons cette
opposition incarnée par les républicains
et par nos amis centristes mais d'où
l'idée alors j'aurai terminé il nous
reste un peu moins de cinq minutes sur
un thème de cette campagne is latif qui
occupe un peu trop l'espace médiatique
depuis deux trois jours c'est la
question du burkini le la décision du
maire de grenoble eric piolle dotoli
d'autoriser le birkin dans les piscines
municipales vous rappelle que
la décision est passé de justesse lors
de son conseil municipal hier 29 voix
pour face à 27 voix contre le sénat
avait interdit de burki me l'an dernier
c'était un amendement du sénateur et
l'air de l'isère michel savin pour je
cite garantir le respect des principes
de neutralité des services publics et de
la laïcité est ce que c'est une limite
il faut changer la loi est ce que c'est
une limite supplémentaires qu'il faut
poser face au communautarisme je suis
pas sûr que ce soit la première
préoccupation des français qui se posent
la question pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux
comment ils vont sourire le pouvoir
d'achat on est bien comment ils vont se
déplacer comment l'hiver prochain ils
vont chauffer d'accord et grinta le
sujet politique que nous devons traiter
un an responsabilité en fait nous voyons
bien ce cas quand même était un choix
que je ne m'explique pas pour des gens
pour lequel j'ai un grand respect
notamment certain nombre de responsables
du parti socialiste de se retrouver dans
cette coalition
avec cette nouvelle union populaire avec
pardonnez-moi
europe écologie les verts ee et la
france a souligé autour de thèmes au
fond quelque part en faisant cet accord
ils ont tourné le dos un principe qu'il
portait encore plus que d'autres mais
que nous portons aussi nous les
gaullistes
l'universalisme de la république aurait
donc ça répond en partie à la question
est-ce qu'il faut une loi pour interdire
les attendait le préfet le préfet à
déférer la délibération au tribunal
administratif nous verrons dans la
réponse du tribunal administratif mais
je regrette je regrette que au moment où
nous avons une texte sur les valeurs de
la république
l'amendement michel savin était renvoyée
d'un revers de main par le la majorité
nous verrons les conclusions
que le tribunal administratif
importera mélange outre
rappelé que c'est pas si une religieuse
mais regagnait c'est en fait l'islamisme
politique l'islamisme
radical qui exigent laurent wauquiez ça
n'est pas un signe religieux laurent
wauquiez
à la liberté du q1 don de vous
interrompre mes laurent et on va
terminer là dessus laurent wauquiez il
n'attend pas la décision d'un tribunal
adminstratif il a décidé de couper les
subventions de la région sait s'adapter
la ville de grâce à sa liberté de
décision si sa liberté décision je dois
dire qu'à un moment faut cesser de
reculer face à cet islamisme politique
qui est contraire je rappelle un texte
qu'on a voté sur les principes de la
république donc vous êtes d'accord avec
la décision de laurent wauquiez je suis
surtout d'accord avec sa décision avec
le recours que le préfet fait et si
nécessaire pas nous devrons légiférer
nous avons eu ce débat dans une
proposition de loi sur le sport car
c'est la même association qui est envoyé
dans les jardins du sénat défaut de bâle
2 ans et jab et je rappelle que il ya un
certain nombre d'éléments pour la vie en
commun vous savez
aristide briand disait la loi doit
protéger la foi elle ne protège la fois
mais tant que la fois où les abus ou le
détournement n'entend pas dicter la loi
merci beaucoup gérard h et d'avoir
accepté notre invitation